[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here
you know what sucks not being able to
recommend a phone
no matter how good it is see every time
huawei drops a new phone i feel like the
conversation we all have is the same
thing over and over which is
it's a great piece of hardware and they
made these advances and here's some new
features
but if you live outside of china
you probably shouldn't get it and even
if you do the experience
is so gutted that is just not worth it
and so what do you know believe it or
not they just dropped
the mate 40 pro and to me this phone
this is the
ultimate expression of like no matter
how good their new phone is
it's impossible to recommend which sucks
because this phone
has some really technically impressive
stuff
you can see this new color slash finish
here on the back of this one they call
it
mystic silver and it has this sheen to
it that reflects
like pretty much every color of the
rainbow depending on what angle you hold
it
which is technically impressive then
around the front you see the huge
display
a roughly 2k 6.76 inch
oled display with a 90 hertz refresh
rate fingerprint reader underneath the
glass of course
and then they're doing what they did
last year with the mate series which is
curving that display
right over the edges until it like melts
into the side of the phone
now you all know how i feel about
actually using curved displays
they create unnecessary accidental
touches they can be frustrating they
cost more
and they're more fragile but huawei's
sticking with it basically because they
look
so dramatic like this one's again curved
so much that they had to move the power
and volume buttons further back on the
phone
and sometimes even the content on the
display or the keyboard itself that
you're typing on
is like melted off of the side
inconvenient
but technically impressive then around
the back there's even more you can see
the camera bump
they're calling this a space ring design
inspired by the first photo of a black
hole
which might be a bit of a stretch but
it's definitely a unique design for the
four cameras that they've put up in this
phone
and because it's in the middle actually
it has the unique benefit of
not rocking as much as most other phones
that put the camera bump in the corner
and the cameras include a 50 megapixel
massive primary sensor one over 1.28
inches
that's nearly rx100 one inch sensor size
so very technically impressive
then there's a 5x periscope telephoto
lens there's a macro camera
and there's a 100 degree ultrawide
camera even the speakers on this phone
go the extra mile so
typically on a flagship phone you'll see
like the speaker grill at the bottom and
then maybe an earpiece
stereo speaker at the top with mate 40
pro they're giving you stereo speakers
with a real second speaker from a grille
at the top
and the earpiece and so the stereo
effect is better
and just in general these speakers get
really loud and they're some of the
loudest i've heard in a smartphone
and they actually sound good so that is
technically
very impressive oh and while we're
talking about what's inside this phone
also has a 4400 milliamp hour battery
pretty solid flagship size cell and it
supports up to
66 watt charging which is insanely fast
you might remember i
just looked at the oneplus 8t with its
65 watt
fast charging so i guess they literally
went up that but that whole thing went
zero to 100 in under 40 minutes which is
crazy
and then on top of that it can do 50
watt
wireless charging which is incredible
now to get that you'll need like the
exact
right wireless charger that's compatible
probably built by huawei and the setup
has to be just right but the fact that
it's able to achieve that at all
is technically impressive then to top
off everything
inside this phone is powered by their
new kirin kiran
karen 9000 chip which is actually a five
nanometer chipset and so this
and apple's a 14 bionic in the new
iphones are the first
five nanometer chipsets shipping and any
smartphones this year so that's of
course
bleeding edge and all those extra
transistors translates generally into
performance and efficiency improvements
now this isn't the review so i haven't
tested battery life and
it almost makes me wonder why they
didn't just go all out and drop 120
hertz display in this phone
if the five nanometer chipset is so
impressive and so efficient
but nevertheless it's on that bleeding
edge it gives you stuff like fusion hdr
video
with real time processing of every frame
and just great overall performance
throwing around apps
in multitasking and throughout this
whole ui and then last
bell whistle there is a pretty big
pillbox cut out in the top corner of the
display which
i was a little worried about at first
because anytime i see that i'm like all
right what did they put up next to the
selfie camera like you have this whole
huge immersive
display with razor thin bezels and you
did a pill box cut out
but inside this one you get a standard
selfie camera
and another 100 degree ultra wide so not
some like pointless monochrome
or depth sensor or anything like that
it's actually a significantly wider
selfie camera
i haven't seen that since the pixel 3 xl
but i thought it was great back then and
i still think it's great now
technically actually you know what that
one's not that technically impressive
they are still
kind of far apart uh it's just smart
it's just smart so huawei's mate series
each year
feels like it's consistently built to
just show off the best that they can
technically achieve
and they have the p series at the
beginning of the year which is typically
more photography focused
and they make a bunch of other phones
but it's just another phone they make
that is
very technically impressive so the story
lately has been
if this is such a good phone then what
are they doing to build up their own
experiences to catch up to what they're
missing
with the lack of google support what are
they actually building and you can see
it's running emui
11 here not my favorite ui as i've
talked about but it doesn't mean there
aren't any nice features
there are multitasking features and
quick launchers and customization and
plenty of stuff like that
but it's the app situation that's still
a sticking point
huawei's app gallery continues to grow
which is great but it's still missing
some pretty fundamental pieces that i
would say most people would find
needed daily on their phone instagram
youtube some of my favorite productivity
apps aren't here
all of the google apps of course and
sometimes i'll actually just
list them in the app gallery but as
literally web apps
so with a link you can see for good
measure it's just launching it in the
browser now first thing while we would
say to that is
they're actually making pretty
significant improvements to their first
party apps
so they're alternatives to stuff we're
used to so they have their own
shopping app they have their own browser
they have their own mapping and
navigation apps
and so that's pretty technically
impressive too but to that i would also
add my take which is
i've always recommended don't buy a
piece of of tech
based on the promise of future software
updates
buy it because it's good now and you'd
be great with it now if it never got
updated
and this app store this app gallery and
all these services being built
they are really great that they're
putting in the work and the effort for
them but they're not
done yet they're not finished being
built yet so they'll continue to make
incredible phones like this but i'll
have to continue waiting
until it's achieved that replacement
level so while huawei's gotten
so good at making technically impressive
hardware the end of the video is still
the same which is like
i wish i could recommend it like imagine
take the logo off of this phone take the
huawei out of this phone and imagine
this phone from someone else the
samsungs
the apples of the world this would be
right up against the bleeding edge of
the stuff that they make
five nanometer chip super crazy wireless
and wired charging tech
all this this camera tech in here it's
it's really good
but i'm not recommending it but all that
being said
i'm so happy to see the effort because
don't think the other companies aren't
noticing this stuff
either way that's been it thanks for
watching a lot more coming soon
in tectober stay tuned catch you guys
later
peace